long
[Music]
back in 08 back in 09 and all that I was
going through some really depressing
times and I just didn't know which way
to go about in life first you have to go
left or right I just didn't know what to
do I was struggling with school
struggling in life I was I was just like
thinking of taking up drugs and all that
sort of stuff and I was just going
through major depression I was even
thinking of suicide and I found a Dean
show I was going through Google and uh
through Islamic websites and all that
sort of stuff I just looked up and then
I saw Dean show
if one person accept Islam because of
you because of your effort at worth more
than holiday this is your brother Abdul
hawalda from Dallas Texas I'm here in
support of the dean center it's a
beautiful organization Masha Allah in
the U.S and they have purchased a piece
of land and several building on it and
we are counting our brother and sister
throughout the US throughout the world
to be part of this magnificent project
it doesn't matter how much you give it
doesn't matter how much you donate what
matter we all participate inshallah may
Allah bless you thank you so much
foreign
[Music]
starting off your day is so important
you know we don't have to get into
science to research to motivational
speakers what they're saying and life
coaches but we have all that in our Dean
we have it we're God Almighty Allah is
talking about
establishing the Salat and the most
important one to get your day going
right is fudger
[Music]
40 years in the making yes yeah future
Generations coming up what's your name
this Abdullah here who's leading the
prayer beautiful so this is a gift it's
Priceless from Allah the dean is
valuable it's money can't buy it's a
gift Allah guided you you're here
tonight continue to go ahead and thank
Allah don't take it for granted and
never think that you're missing out and
you see him on the hip-hop videos in
there for two three minutes it looks
like wow this is it this is life but
when the cameras are off some of the
most miserable people in his latest
Instagram post the singer admits he was
unhappy during his last tour and is now
quote very focused on repairing some of
the deep-rooted issues that I have so
that I don't fall apart
because they don't have Dean they don't
have purpose
and the drugs and the money and the
girls and all this stuff is fake it's a
fake life so you're really you're living
the real life inshallah we can be in
Jannah GPS to gender and we'll see you
soon after all of you guys at the dean
Center inshallah very close to the dean
Center you got El Medina Grocery Store
and restaurant so you got a high
concentration of a community look at
this look look at somehow it looks you
know we stay away from the sugar but I'm
good thank you very much I do uh that's
good
the first time here right the first time
okay the first time
thank you
how you doing
[Music]
my name is
nice to meet you nice to meet you I see
you all the time and this is Muslims for
Humanity tell us about that so my
volunteer comes here uh every Saturday
and they pack the food as you can see we
do give nice good food for the for the
for the needy families here and
everything we do is dawa in action so we
do give variety of stuff the canned food
you know a good stuff and there's people
who donate meat also alhamdulillah I'm
so honored to have brother Eddie with us
feeding Humanity that means we serve all
mankind regardless who you are we don't
look to people's color and fate and all
discrimination no discrimination at all
you get fed you get fit I spent 24 years
in South Florida I'm so happy to be here
in Tampa it's been five years I
discovered Tampa is a beautiful
wonderful place and there's a lot of
programs in different Center there is a
Unity here there's something it brings
everybody together sometimes you could
attend this Center for doher and Maury
could go to the center and maybe you can
catch up Asia another Center it is
continuing to grow oh yeah the community
is growing everybody's moving here from
day to day I mean every day you hear
that a lot of people coming from all
over the country
Center any kind of relief will be
working together to feed our neighbors
around this area around the dean Center
absolutely it will be an honor and that
we're very uh honored to have you with
us here in Tampa and you know every
single year all of us were proud what
you do with what you're doing for that
it's amazing and my my Allah the Creator
make you more blessing to this beautiful
community and we mean it from our heart
all right
and what he did today they still talk
about it I'm here with some denizens
here from the area in Tampa Brothers uh
they want to know like what is the
situation here in Tampa is fine as far
as when we opened the dean Center the
sustainability with Community here can
you give people a better picture
so alhamdulillah really I can tell you
guys that I've been now Tampa now for
five years before that I lived 10 12
years in Saint Pete so not too far off
really alhamdulillah what I've seen in
the Tampa Community the potential
mashallah the people who come out to
support events support initiatives
support centers here is really fantastic
and we thank Allah this is a great narma
it's a great blessing that alhamdulillah
you know as our brother he said here
earlier that Tampa is a city mashallah
and an area where people are generous
whether they have or they don't have
they're willing to give alhamdulillah so
really I see brother Eddie inshallah
when you get your Center open when your
Center is going especially see a project
like this people they want things like
this they want things which are they are
sincere towards the dean of Allah you
know they want initiatives which are
going to help with that one help is
some people are asking is a Masjid in
this area where we're at Valrico is it
needed definitely going to fill a vacuum
you couldn't have picked a better Moment
In Time
to fill this void speaking with people
that are like us in the community it's
been uh thirsty for that for multiple
years so I think it's probably one of
the best investments I've seen in the
past two to three years in regards to
things that can happen in the city it's
definitely going to fill a lot of voids
and the key thing is everything that
he's trying to do brother Eddie is
exactly what the community needs Heaven
Sent however you want to say it it's
definitely written for him to do what he
just did I could not
support anything better than this type
of cause due to the fact that you're
filling a void a vacuum it was it was
written for you about it
because there's no other Islamic Center
or Michigan within that city of Valrico
so definitely a huge Community like that
is there in presence and Islamic school
and Islamic Center at that was Center
inshallah is going to be a fantastic
initiative how important is the dean
center for the future generations to
come
that's a an issue like this is something
that's long overdue not just in Florida
Valrico rather in the US you know this
is as you guys probably know this one
the biggest projects Islamic projects
hopping the whole United States you know
a place where people worshipers youth
can come practice learn their religion
as well as non-muslims can come learn
about Islam get support as new Muslims
inshallah where youth can come they can
gather they can do activities we can
have Islamic schools Etc this is the
type of measures we need In America
which are they're not just places of
worship at their centers they're
communal centers for our communities
together learn benefits again it's once
it's an honor which is totally an honor
to have a person like you here you are
going to be one of the backbones
Jesus
quite frankly I was quite surprised when
I found out that he's gonna transfer me
in this call
maybe the smallest car I ever been at
even though I come from Egypt and I
wouldn't have cars almost until I was a
teenager but in America here
you know this is the car Eddie had to
rent
you know to go around you know he's from
Chicago right but he's now in Florida
next to the lean Center
and
see that place out there
that's where we're
you know I I asked him something what's
going on he said Amanda Sheikh you know
a Mana ship
you know I really had to I had to convey
this to you guys because
I tell you something I'm an Imam but my
standard even a little bit more than
that
and he just humbled me
you know now I'm questioning my
Integrity here
I ask Allah to forgive all of us
we need to do this for the future of our
children the future of our great country
the future of mankind this is your
brother and I've got a very important
message alhamdulillah our brother Eddie
is setting up the dean Center not just
the dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it
[Music]